[Music]
we're broadcasting from rio de janeiro
brazil tonight one of the most famous
cities in the world and for good reason
certainly one of the most beautiful on
the planet you're looking at the christ
the redeemer statue that's in the summit
of mount corcovado
an amazing statute built in the early
30s
we're going to go there later in the
week
so the january 6 committee has nothing
to do with january 6. the point of it is
to punish the political opponents of the
biden administration and to make certain
donald trump doesn't run again and
they're doing it with the assistance of
the so-called justice department as run
by joe biden so already the committee
speaking of stalinist overreach has had
steve bannon and peter navarro arrested
neither of whom committed any crime
they've also had the fed searched the
home of a former doj official called
jeffrey clark who we spoke to last week
then on wednesday the fbi showed up to
seize the phone of a former trump
attorney called john eastman now
critically and illegally they seized his
phone before they presented him with a
warrant and it's on tape watch
so we're going to put your arms off for
me can i put your actions up
i'd like to see the wine
i'd like to see the warrant
i'd like to see the warrant
i'd like to see the warrant before you
take my property
i want you to see
that they took my property before
providing me with the warrant
i'd like to read the word disgraceful
wearing his little mask put your hands
up as if eastman is the thread he's not
he's a lawyer as you just saw he's under
subpoena from the speaking of
illegitimate wholly illegitimate
pelosi liz cheney-led january 6
committee mr eastman joins us tonight
john eastman thank you so much for
joining us tonight
what exactly did you do wrong to be
treated like a dangerous criminal by
your government that you pay for
well we don't know because the warrant
doesn't say it authorizes them to seize
my phone and all the information
contained in the phone but there's no
indication of uh of of any crime that
this is connected to
that's apparently in an attach in an
affidavit but the affidavit wasn't
attached to the warrant the fourth
amendment's very clear here uh when they
search and seize your property they have
to give a particular description of the
things to be seized and in saying it's
identified in the affidavit if they
don't attach the affidavit doesn't
qualify the courts have been very clear
about that so this this warrant is
invalid on its face
but more importantly and and i think
this is extremely important the the
authority to seize all of my information
in modern modern smartphones that's
access to all my private financial
records i'm an attorney it's access to
all my privileged communications with
nearly 100 different clients that i have
currently
this stuff this stuff
is what we used to call a general
warrant that the british king issued to
just go rummage through somebody's
belongings to see if they could find
evidence of some crime the very reason
we have the fourth amendment is to
prevent that kind of abuse and yet
that's what they're doing here
and it's just another reminder anyone
who didn't vote for joe biden to erase
your texts and emails every single day
and that is a sincere piece of advice i
hope everyone follows but they haven't
charged you with a crime they've given
you no evidence that they're going to
charge you with a crime but they treat
you like a drug kingpin or a rapist
and seize your phone
is this legal
i don't think so and uh they forced me
in the position look i as an attorney i
have ethical obligations to do
everything i can to protect the
privileged communications with my
clients so we will be filing a motion
it's called a rule 41 motion to retrieve
my phone to retrieve any information
they've taken off of that phone that
they have illegally ceased from me uh
and we'll be doing that uh in in short
order but but you know what they're
doing the other thing they're doing is
they're forcing those of us that you
know don't bow the need to the biden
administration to rack up hundreds of
thousands of dollars in legal fees
trying to protect our constitutional
rights and those of our clients
so let me let me ask people give sendgo
dot com eastman help us help us fight
this abuse we've got it we've got to
stand together to fight against this
so you're doing for yourself what the
republican congress should be doing for
you
which is so stressful they should but
you know what i got speed i think people
have had it thank you very much tucker
i hope that's true
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight